Speaker 1: Donald Trump is threatening.
That his followers will do terrible things
if the persecution that he believes is unfair
of him continues. Trump used coded language
in an interview with Fox Nation. But any of
us who have been following American politics
and who know what happened on January 6th can
tell this is Trump saying, I've got leverage.
And my followers will do terrible things. This is
Donald Trump speaking out for the first time since
the search warrant was served at Mar a Lago.
And you really have to parse the language to
understand what Donald Trump is saying. Trump
is saying that terrible things will happen,
meaning someone will do the terrible things. If
you say terrible things will happen, they will
be done by someone. So then the question is, well,
who is it that would be doing those things? Well,
it's the people Trump says won't stand for
another witch hunt. Well, that sounds like
he's talking about his own followers. And what are
the circumstances under which these people will
do the terrible things? If the temperature
is not brought down? What does that mean?
It means if the investigations into Donald Trump
continue, let's take a look at it, because again,
you've got to look at the language to understand
this. Trump will do whatever he can to, quote,
help the country after the raid.
Temperature has to be brought down.
So we start looking at the quotes from Donald
Trump. During this interview, Trump said The
country is in a very dangerous position. There
is tremendous anger like I've never seen before
over all of the scams and this new one years
of scams and witch hunts and now this. Okay, so
there is tremendous anger. Who's angry? His
followers. Reasonable people who understand.
Merrick Garland signed off on this search
warrant after significant consideration.
Christopher Wray, the FBI director who was
selected by Trump, okayed it. A judge okayed it.
We're not angry. We understand the legality of
this search. When Trump says there is tremendous
anger, he's talking about his followers
and he says that it's over scams. Well,
no sane, rational person believes that this
is a scam. We understand it for what it is,
a legal search warrant. So he's talking
about his followers. That's number one.
Trump then says If there is anything we can do to
help, I and my people would be willing to do that.
What could that be? Well, maybe the DOJ
says, hey, we're backing off and Trump goes
to his followers and says, Hey, they're
backing off. Let's turn down the temperature.
Trump goes on to say, There has never been a time
like this where law enforcement has been used
to break into the house of a former president.
And there is tremendous anger at a level that
has never been seen before other than during
very perilous times. That's Trump linking
the anger of his followers to the peril. Well,
what is it that they might do? Trump said,
I will do whatever I can to help the country. And
then going on, this is really the sort of critical
moment of what Donald Trump in the interview
talks about. The FBI might have planted stuff.
They could have taken anything.
They could have put anything in.
We weren't given access to the search. But
then this is really the critical point.
Trump says people are so angry at what is taking
place. Whatever we can do to help because the
temperature has to be brought down in the country.
If it isn't terrible, things are going to happen.
So understand that terrible things will happen.
Someone will do them if the temperature is not
brought down. Well, who's running hot? It's his
followers. Why are his followers running hot?
Because of the search warrant and the criminal
investigations that Trump is under. Therefore,
Trump is saying his followers will do terrible
things if the temperature isn't brought down
by law enforcement laying off of him.
Look at what people are making Trump do
understand Trump isn't making a prediction here.
Trump's making a threat. As the article points
out. He's offering to do anything to turn the
temperature down. He can end this. He can say to
supporters, I lost the election. We must respect
democracy. We must respect the rule of law. Due
process was adhered to in this search. Nobody did
anything wrong here other than me. But he won't.
And he wants to keep the possibility of his
supporters becoming violent as leverage. He knows
it. It's abundantly clear. And by the way, Tucker
Carlson is playing it up as well. Tucker Carlson
last night played this up in the same language.
Speaker 4: It's just something unprecedented
and something awful. You could feel it. Even
Donald Trump feels it. Maybe for the first time in
his life, Donald Trump seems sincerely interested
in lowering the temperature not just for his own
sake, but for the country. He said that he's never
said anything like that. Maybe he doesn't mean it.
But what does he ever said that let's all
calm down a little, he said the other day.
Speaker 1: And of course, Tucker is not
acknowledging that what Trump said is coded
language for my people will become violent
if this continues. But Tucker is pretending
like Trump is genuinely trying to calm everybody
down. That's not what he's doing. Trump's trying
to get himself out of trouble.
Speaker 4: This isn't good.
Yeah, he's right. It's not
good. And not just for him.
For all of us. This could get very bad. Very fast.
Speaker 1: Yes. And it would get bad fast if
Donald Trump six his followers on law enforcement,
FBI, DOJ and violent protests. So playing it up
is Tucker Carlson. And of course, everything
that was done is completely legal and kosher.
Where will this go in the next 7 to 10 days?
I don't know. But it's sort of scaring me,